[Music]  it turns out this is a story I read  about this that the majority of Lego  people the little people that come when  you get a Lego set the figures that are  manufactured these days the majority of  them have unhappy or upset facial  expressions look at that the majority  then they went through look at all those  faces they went through and they studied  the Lego faces of the figures most of  them have unhappy or upset expressions I  got this perturbed me okay I grew up  with Legos my kids loved Legos we all  love Legos I think it's time we do our  part to cheer up these little Lego guys  so we're gonna do that right now  take a look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]